[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
[Musique]
un podcast original produit par Lina
écrit par les avenstein avec le concours
de Dominique Missika
[Musique]
15 avril 1944
après deux jours et demi d'un transport
insupportable le convoi numéro 71 partie
de Drancy arrive à Auschwitz birkena
Simone Veil sa sœur Milou et leur mère
Yvonne débarquent sur le quai au milieu
de la nuit
[Musique]
Simone Veil seul l'espoir apaise la
douleur
deuxième épisode à Auschwitz avril
juillet 1944
[Musique]
le train s'arrête boscomment très vite
les portières s'ouvrent puisque ce sont
des wagons abestiaux des gens pyjama
avec
rayé qui se précipite qui nous font
sortir très vite les aboiements de chien
cet éclairage très dur du fait qu'il y a
sur le quai ces lampes
projetées vers la lumière projetée vers
les wagons et puis une sortie très très
rapide des wagons avec ses bagnards pour
nous ils sont habillés comme des
bagnards et qui nous font sortir des
trains les chiens qui aboient
tout ça se passe très très vite certains
ont ça m'a un petit bagage moi j'ai
l'impression de j'avais rien je veux pas
voir le sac à main d'ailleurs pas
l'impression d'avoir eu quoi que ce soit
bon d'autres n'ont pas lâché leur petite
je me souviens d'une amie qui avait
gardé comme ça à son sac où il y avait
un petit flacon de parfum ou des choses
comme enfin des choses personnelles mais
sans ça aucune réalise aucune rien
vraiment uniquement ce est tout petit
bagages on est mis dehors et puis
mis en rond sous ses projecteurs
et puis un
de ces bagnards qui est français
vraisemblablement et choisissent je
pense toujours des gens qui sont de la
nationalité de ce du convoi qui arrive
ça les aide ça leur permet non pas de
tranquilliser mais que les gens
comprennent il faut qu'ils se mettent en
France il y en a qui me dit qu'elle a je
vous avais je dis 16 ans et demi dites
que vous avez 18 ans et ça c'est arrivé
à beaucoup de d'entre nous enfin parmi
les jeunes en sachant que à 16 ans
quelquefois on entre dans le camp mais
que très souvent n'entre pas ton état 18
c'est l'âge
et donc on se met en rang nous on entre
toutes les trois donc on ne se rend pas
compte si vous voulez très bien de ce
qui se passe sinon qu'on voit qu'il y en
a qu'on met de côté quand il y a des
enfants des gens qui disent qu'ils sont
fatigués ou autre toutes les trois on se
pose même pas la question comme toutes
les trois on est mis ensemble etc on dit
même pas qu'on est fatigué ni rien on
est et sans doute tout chercher à
comprendre et on imaginant
qu'effectivement les camions vont nous
les gens qui ont les camions vont nous
rejoindre mais on se pose pas beaucoup
la question à ce moment là la rampe
n'est pas encore la nouvelle rampe
jusqu'à montrer mon histoire n'est pas
encore créé c'est juste avant et donc on
va à pied jusqu'à
ce que dans à l'intérieur du camp on est
dans une espèce de bâtiment
en béton où il y a rien il y a rien il y
a quelques fenêtres dans les coins on
s'assoit on se met par terre on essaye
de dormir
et on parle entre nous et puis celles
qui n'ont
prenons de quelques heures comme ça les
celles qui sont avec nous qui avaient
des la famille qui sont montés dans le
camion
t'inquiète pas ne rien puis les capots
commencent à venir des déporter on
commence à nous dire si vous avez des
bijoux si vous avez de l'argent
donnez-le nous parce que toute façon on
ne garde rien du tout alors autant nous
le donner
j'avais une amie qui était venue avec
nous Nice déjà qui avait souviens
toujours elle avait un flacon de parfum
je rachète le même de temps en temps
toujours en pensant en pensant à elle et
alors parce qu'on a entièrement mis sur
nous plutôt que l'idée que ça nous
serait pris et
puis on attend on les entend elle nous
disent des choses épouvantables on
écoute pas
et puis on essaie même pas de dormir
parce que c'est
ça doit être faire 5 6 heures du matin
arrive alors toute une un groupe de
capots les unes pour nous raser pour
nous raser la tête d'autres pour et tout
ce qui peut y avoir parce qu'on peut
avoir comme poil sur le sur le corps
avec tout de même cette chance et la
signale parce que c'est important qui a
été que dans ce qu'on voit la plupart
des femmes n'ont pas eu les cheveux
rasés ça on s'en est rendu compte
ensuite que les autres normalement
quelques-unes ont les cheveux rasées
mais très peu en principe alors on a les
cheveux coupés courts mais pas rasés ce
qui est tout de même psychologiquement
très très différents et puis ensuite
le tatouage alors évidemment le tatouage
c'est ça ne fait pas mal ma femme on se
dit si on est tatoué c'est que d'abord
on est plus considéré comme des numéros
mais surtout c'est que on n'est pas
destiné à sortir d'ici enfin c'est
quelque chose qui restera pour toute la
vie ça c'est la chose à laquelle on
pense et puis comment ça courir le bruit
enfin on commence à nous dire ou plutôt
comme celle qui était la plupart avait
de la famille qui était parti assez rare
les gens qui sont non pas une famille
soit partis dans les camions a demandé
et c'est là où les les capots les blocs
les anciens commencent à dire mais
regarde la fumée voilà ils ont été gazés
et c'est fini et on a
vraiment on croit que c'est
l'intoxication on n'arrive pas à le
croire
ce qui montre que nous n'avions pas pu
imaginer même quand il y avait eu les
camions qui on est personne n'a hésité à
prendre le camion et
on a donc un numéro
c'est assez commode d'avoir un numéro
moi maintenant quand j'ai
pour
un numéro donc je vais être sûr de me
souvenir
je sais pas pour un coffre pour une clé
je prends j'ai deux dates comme ça j'ai
mon numéro et puis
le 18 janvier 45 c'est
18h45 j'ai un certain nombre de choses
comme ça
j'ai une petite valise que j'aime
fermer chez moi
c'est ce qui me sert de numéro
bien sûr on va l'oublier mais aussi le
18 janvier 45
[Musique]
alors on est en reste entre nous dans le
même bloc tout ensemble en quarantaine
mais en fait
on a travaillé pendant la quarantaine
c'est à dire que ça changeait tous les
jours mais que comme il y avait des
wagons le carré avec les pierres qu'il
fallait décharger ou charger qu'il y
avait toujours des choses à nettoyer à
niveler à autre en fait on est resté
très peu de temps dans le bloc
complètement et très rapidement même
pendant la quarantaine
on a fait du terrassement ce qui était
la grande occupation dans les temps pour
tous ceux qui ne savaient pas faire
quelque chose utilisable dans une usine
ou autre que pouvait avoir les
c'était les pierres
il y avait des wagons très vite très
très vite on a
déchargé des pierres de wagons qui
arrivaient ce qui construisait ce que je
pense tous ces travaux de terrassement
c'est toujours demandé il servait parce
que certains là je crois que les pierres
il y en avait besoin mais sans ça très
souvent on transportait des trucs on
faisait des fossés on notait toutes les
pierres d'un terrain là c'est à plus
tard alors quand j'étais à
beaubreak qui a un terrain tout plein on
passait son temps au terrain à ôter des
pierres il y avait eu des pierres dans
le terrain mais jamais compris à quoi ça
servait si vous voulez en faire un
tennis
vous connaissez déjà Marceline vous la
rencontrez dans le camp non j'ai
rencontré
quand non je la connaissais pas du tout
nous on était resté très peu de temps à
Drancy on était resté entre nous donc
c'est assez rapidement qu'on se
rencontre au camp parce qu'on est parmi
les plus jeunes un peu plus jeune que
moi
il y avait Sonia enfin on était quelques
plus jeunes il y avait Laurette aussi
Laurette qui était danseuse et qui va
danser pour la chef du camp SS qui
aimait les voir danser et en même temps
avoir un petit job bon alors on était
au moins 10 à être nettement plus jeune
que les autres
et alors il y a un grand si vous voulez
entre avoir 16 ans 15 ans et demi 18 et
puis alors celles qui ont plus de 18 ans
c'est
alors qui parle de leurs amours qui
parlent de leur vie et déjà faite et
nous on a les petites
qui sont là traînés partout écoutez
partout qui cherche à ne pas travailler
c'est curieux parce que ma sœur qui
était harvestro qu'elle m'a dit que
c'était un peu la même chose il y avait
aussi un décalage entre celle qui était
alors là c'était plutôt autour de 20 ans
et puis celle qui était qui avait déjà
une vie plus organisée et que celle qui
était plus âgée trouvait toujours que
les jeunes étaient insupportables
nous c'était curieux l'attitude des
femmes qui avaient 25 ans enfin moi je
l'ai entendu par exemple certaines dire
avant vous êtes jeune bon alors vous
savez pas ce que c'est de la vie vous
savez pas ce que vous perdez n'a l'air
de dire presque
il y avait des rivalités d'âge entre les
Marceline et moi on sait tout de suite
on est devenu très amis avec deux ou
trois autres mais surtout moi c'est
surtout avec Marceline que je me suis
lié au camp avec de temps en temps la
volonté d'échapper au travail et de se
cacher dans un coin pour ne pas aller
travailler c'était
l'ancien ne pas aller travailler c'était
plus facile pendant la quarantaine
qu'ensuite ensuite ensuite on était
affecté dans du commando enfin c'était
beaucoup plus difficile pendant
quarantaine c'était on est arrivé
plusieurs de trois fois enfin on se
cachait un peu pour le départ des
commandos une fois qu'il s'était parti
c'était on restait on va cadre dans le
camp essayer de voir un peu
ce qui avait et c'est comme ça qu'une
fois d'ailleurs on est tombé sur le blog
des communistes françaises dont on garde
l'une et l'autre
souvenir horrible pourquoi parce que
nous on a entendu parler français alors
on était très contents on a dit tiens il
y a un blog de françaises on savait pas
qu'elle j'étais et donc on s'est
approché à ce moment-là elles étaient
arrivées tôt elles sont arrivées en 142
ou 40 début 43 je sais plus et elle
avait eu un début de travail au camp et
de conditions de vie très dur il y avait
une épidémie typhus enfin à ce moment là
on s'approche et on commence à leur
parler
Marceline elle avait 15 ans et demi moi
j'avais pas 17 ans j'ai commencé à leur
parler et elle nous traite de sale juive
pratiquement
en disant écoutez si vous avez fait de
la résistance vous n'en seriez pas là
[Musique]
alors moi ensuite quand on m'a parlé la
solidarité je dois dire que
Marceline et moi quand on nous parle de
la solidarité dans les camps
même entre si vous voulez des portations
différentes ça nous laisse un peu
sceptique
voilà c'est un souvenir pour l'une et
l'autre très amer elle nous aurait dit
bon vous êtes très bien suivent bon
mais cet agressivité
à notre rencontre un peu Marceline
encore plus que moi qui était bon était
vraiment
[Musique]
tout à fait
passer mais on l'aurait oublié
facilement si au retour on n'avait pas
entendu un discours pour nous expliquer
qu'il y avait eu une
solidarité générale parce que ça c'est
intéressant le problème de la solidarité
parce qu'il y en a eu à la fois plus et
moins qu'on me le dit d'abord quand les
gens étaient en famille
plupart du temps au sein d'une famille
la solidarité s'il y avait deux ou trois
personnes c'est on a vécu les uns sur
les autres enfin c'est même en dehors de
ça il y a eu très souvent on avait
la copine qu'on avait connu à la prise
en prison ou à Drancy ou autre ou
travaillant et donc il y avait des
petites solidarités et entre lesquelles
les gens ils partagent tout souvent je
voyais notamment
c'est ces petites polonaises au
Slovaques qui étaient devenus bloc-elle
chef de bloc ou capot ou n'importe quoi
et qui était quelquefois très dur parce
qu'elles étaient depuis fin 39 dans le
déco ghetto que j'avais perdu toute la
famille quelquefois de sous leurs yeux
dans les ghettos 30 ou 40 personnes
comme ça d'un seul coup fusil ou autre
alors elle s'était beaucoup endurcie et
je me dis toujours la plupart du temps
comme elles étaient là depuis longtemps
j'avais j'occupais certaines
postes de responsabilités je me disais
elles ont une chose qu'il reste c'est
qu'entre elles sont capables de partager
n'importe quoi c'est à dire que elle
donne leur vie l'une pour l'autre et au
moins ça reste des sentiments humains
sans celles n'aurait plus rien du parce
que comme elles n'ont que personne elles
n'ont plus rien quand elles lutte elle
lutte pour elle mais aussi pour la
copine et très souvent il y a eu tout de
même beaucoup de ce genre de solidarité
pas seulement pour une amie mais de voir
quelqu'un en grande difficulté
les gens n'ont pas fait contrairement à
ce qu'on dit les gens n'ont pas fait du
tout n'importe quoi je veux dire il y a
eu des histoires de mère et fille qui
sont terribles moi qu'on a entendu comme
ça moi j'ai entendu comme ça une
je sais plus si c'est la mère qui était
venue rejoindre sa fille qui avait été
arrêté ou le contraire
celle qui est venue retrouver l'autre et
morte et l'autre pas enfin c'est des
histoires terribles
il y avait pas beaucoup de mer n'avait
très peu on avait très peu parce que
comme
compte tenu de l'âge à laquelle on était
admis dans le camp minimum
et de l'âge maximum ça faisait une très
petite fourchette enfin très peu de
monde qui remplissent vous les deux
remplissez la condition et maman c'était
un peu miraculeux parce que elle aurait
été des habillée on n'aurait pas pris
parce qu'elle avait été opérée la
vésicule biliaire et que non ou deux
avant et que ça ne s'était jamais
cicatrisé donc si on n'avait pas passé
le sélection à ce moment-là j'amène
serait entré dans le camp mais elle se
tenait très droites elle était très
digne très belle et c'est comme ça
qu'elle était entrée dans le camp
enfin je sais pas très peu de mes amis
ont gardé en fait il y avait très très
peu d'adultes dans
il y avait pas mal de femmes 30-35 ans
mais ne pouvait pas à ce moment-là même
si elles avaient des enfants d'abord sur
la plupart si elles avaient des enfants
n'étaient pas entrés parce que c'est les
enfants jeunes et qu'elle s'était resté
avec leurs enfants voilà il y en avait
tout de même quelques-unes mais c'était
plutôt
des jeunes filles ou des jeunes femmes
dont les parents étaient plus âgés et
les parents n'étaient pas entrés ou des
frères et soeurs du jeûne
qui n'était pas rentré dans le camp
[Musique]
là moi j'ai l'impression surtout d'avoir
été gardé par des SS pas tellement par
des capots et alors dans les blocs
c'était le chef de blocs ça c'est des
très souvent les Juifs polonaises au
Slovaques qui avait été très jeune
quelquefois mais qui était là depuis
très longtemps et puis les Françaises on
était handicapés toute façon vous pouvez
pas avoir de poste responsabilité sauf
celle qui était d'origine polonaise ou
qui était d'origine allemande et qui
parlait mais sans ça on parlait
uniquement français elle était pas
imaginable ni qu'on travaille dans les
bureaux ni qu'on travaille et encore ce
handicap il a été beaucoup plus lourd
pour les Grecs et les hollandaises parce
que alors là elle avait parlé des
langues personnes d'autres parlait elles
étaient très perdue très perche vous
rappelez d'une certaine sténia
sténia oui ça c'est une polonaise non
juive qui m'a aidé enfin j'ai jamais
encore maintenant je me demande pourquoi
elle m'a aidé je ne sais pas elle était
plus que capot elle était chef du camp
déporté je crois comme prostituée ou
comme moi comme un et elle était la
responsable du camp au point de vue si
vous voulez comme des portées mais elle
était au dessus des capots et de tourner
les blancs
elle
bon j'ai dit j'ai dit que j'avais eu la
chance
qu'on n'est pas les cheveux rasés en
plus je peux rester pratiquement moi je
vivais à Nice j'avais même à dû aller à
la plage ou en tout cas au soleil ou
n'importe quoi vivre dans une famille ou
en plus
on vivait pas mal
la vie était plus facile dans cette
famille je vais voir où j'habitais que
ce que nous avions eu auparavant j'avais
plus de facilité matérielle financière
enfin recevait les paquets je crois de
la campagne c'était on avait une vie qui
était une vie matérielle relativement
facile alors j'avais bonne mine je suis
resté quelques jours seulement à
l'Excelsior et quelques jours à Nancy
donc quand je suis arrivé à birkenan
j'étais physiquement
en très bonne forme en plus
en plus j'étais j'avais la peau brune
j'avais 16 ans 17 ans et je me souviens
déjà pendant la ce qui était d'ailleurs
très désagréable très pénible ces filles
elles étaient depuis long temps donc des
boutons sur la peau des fois très abîmés
alors quand elle voyait tout d'un coup
une fille qui avait l'air de sortir de
la plage et autres elles étaient toutes
là vous taper c'était un peu
le supporter alors as-tu montré du doigt
et là c'était nia ça n'a pas du tout été
comme ça simplement
en passant quand on sortait du camp pour
aller dans les travaux de terrassement
on était par tranche de 5
et c'est elle qui était toujours elle
c'était une de ses fonctions c'était de
contrôler les départs et les arrivées
une fois elle m'a vu elle m'a arrêté
elle m'a dit tu es trop jolie pour
mourir ici je vais essayer de faire
quelque chose pour toi alors ce qu'il y
avait arrangé les choses je dois dire
c'était parce que les choses sont
toujours un peu cumulatives dans ce il y
avait l'histoire des cheveux mais les
cheveux c'était presque tout le convoi
mais il y avait une jeune juive
polonaise qui était rescapé du du ghetto
de Varsovie des dernières qui avaient
sorti il y avait été à l'autre après
puis qui était là et qui était
architecte et elle parlait français un
peu pas très bien mais enfin elle
parlait pas mal français et je crois que
c'était un dimanche je m'entend parler
français et elle me dit oh une Française
etc elle m'a dit parce que je serais
contente de parler avec une Française et
elle me dit de devenir dans son blog on
va voir et
j'étais alors là comme celle quand on
arrive en quarantaine on a des haillons
des espèces de trucs de chiffon qu'on
essaye de mettre sur soi mais qui était
épouvantable elle me dit écoute vraiment
je vais essayer que tu es une robe
convenable alors quand elle était
architecte pour moi elle rendait service
sur les avait plus à manger j'en sais
rien plus je parle ça il y avait un troc
énorme dans les temps et elle me dit
pour une portion de pain elle m'a acheté
elle m'a acheté deux ou trois robes qui
étaient à ma taille et d'ailleurs j'ai
une amie Ginette
que je vois souvent très souvent à
toutes les manifestations vont se
rencontrer qui est aussi très aussi dans
les jeunes c'était aussi une amie de
Marceline et qui me dit il n'y a qu'une
personne mais j'avais donné quelque
chose tu m'as donné une robe moi j'avoue
bien complètement que j'avais donné une
robe on avait pas le même gabarit le
fait d'avoir à la fois
bonne mine une robe une robe convenable
etc c'était on est tout de même elle m'a
dit bon et je suis la seule personne qui
n'a jamais qu'elle n'est jamais aidé
alors tout de suite je lui m'a sorti
durant
avec ma mère et ma sœur et je dis elle
m'a dit ben je
veux faire quelque chose pour toi et on
parlait beaucoup d'un petit camp qui
était juste à côté en réalité j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était plus loin et
c'est en y retournant une autre fois on
y allant que j'ai vu c'est tout près
mais on faisait un grand détour autour
de je suis pour y aller alors que
c'était à 4 km enfin c'était rien et
mais j'avais entendu parler de ce camp
on parlait de sanatorium Bob break comme
de l'endroit où on pouvait vivre
survivre et je dis on part
c'est toutes les trois elle m'a dit
d'accord alors j'ai attendu bon quelque
chose et puis au bout de quelques jours
on était convoqué toutes les trois et là
j'ai eu vraiment une
je me suis dit qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait une folie parce que j'ai vu
que on devait passer un examen enfin
contrôle médical et qui avait le
contrôle médical se passait devant ma
gueule et qu'il a mis naturellement
maman avait toujours cette on était nu
et qu'il a mis mon côté
et là alors ce qui est là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'elle
est vraiment à ce qu'on parle
parce que
elle a elle a dit parler mais elle lui
dit pour maman que c'était elle qui
avait pris cet engagement et donc on est
parti toutes les trois
[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
un podcast original en quatre épisodes
produit par Lina
réalisée par mexomnoises écrit par les
avenstein avec le concours de Dominique
Missika
avec la voix d'isadorada musique
originale Michael yo
[Musique]
ce podcast a été réalisé à partir du
témoignage de Simone Veil recueilli par
Catherine Bernstein le 9 mai 2006 dans
le cadre de mémoire de la Shoah une
initiative de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah et de Lina
[Musique]